how about that when I get offstage at
the Laugh Factory right away you go bro
I figure out what you look like I'm like
why this front a bunch other comics I'm
like what you're like you look like a
Rottweiler we got a shitty got that mic
so either you're not gonna influence
Indian children do it I don't think a
lot of Indian kids like it to be like I
want to [ __ ] you know look like a
French Paul Bunyan when I get older
no I'm saying do you look like Paul
Bunyan if you just drank champagne all
day and never did any forestry because
man you don't know yourself that well
you gotta get a better mirror man using
[ __ ] cheap mirrors you got $111 socks
and cheap mirrors dude Wow bro my
backyard I thought I can't believe feel
doesn't have like that there's certain
annals that just go with other people
I'm like dude I feel a walk just put my
like I just raised to stretch in the
morning this is possum hanging from
under my arm like I would be surprised
if we surprised you at your house is
like I don't know some sort of cool
breakfast and like I woke you up me at a
possum your bed and doctor's wife so
then big tick like now it's surprising
at all cuz you're a younger version of
dog just trying to [ __ ] sitting Brian
can't see it's little too close and they
slowly start turning you can I can tell
if when I first came here they're a
little more straighter and then over the
years I just keep this Brian y'all
[ __ ] just morph into one hideous
the bright one be closed for whatever
reason so yeah I feel like I'm in
business class crisis crisis but no I
got a cousin they're always guys I don't
have much of bees one time on a picnic
and yeah that's similar
what I'm saying is that they uh that
this man got the time you probably felt
weird about stopping fighting you know
yeah skin and now you feel okay about it
you know well now he's got [ __ ] you
know two podcasts that basically if
you're in the fight world you know you
better know yeah now you're basically
the tall Italian Oprah Italian Oprah
dude the Ryan Seacrest of fight you
don't want to start focusing to learning
more Spanish so I can I want to do a
special in like Spanish yeah like a
Nicaragua or something my dad's from
Nicaragua it's only do a special in
Nicaragua yeah dad is not Nicaraguan I'm
uh we're gonna edit that out there
because that time closer okay go one
more time but I want to see how racist
this is up make a wrong win broke a
couple of guys I shut the door dude you
can't even speak on kratom can you you
say it Nicaraguan bro you're yes broke
my father's from blue fields Nicaragua
lisinga rocks why do you know I'm not
like uh yeh look like you're holding
water in the face a little bit yeah a
little bit
are you a little I'm sure are you on
creatine no no maybe just carved a young
creatine uh uh you have a stepdad he was
in the war right and he made my sister
get on creatine because he was real lazy
dude he thought it was gonna help with
like laziness so she was just lazy and
[ __ ] on creatine she just get all
bloated yeah
but it didn't help anything she said
honestly their message is pretty wild
huh she got well she got she said she
felt like her body turned into a
waterbed that's when she's fit because
she was as I guess is holding water
that's hold water and she was sleep more
than you know yeah that so we kind of
did the opposite just that comfort yeah
you ever been on that creatine oh yeah
when it first came out dude it was a big
deal may not hide that [ __ ] in my ass
kids were doing anything for it but when
it first came out yeah creatine is a big
deal I ran a grape flavor oh not cheap
yeah it's like 4050 but least to get
Jack no water Jack they call her jack
yeah that water smoke oh yeah you could
cut somebody and [ __ ] and uh feed
your plants you know sure they still do
it but I know that Brad first time I
ever saw him dude I was at USC right I
mean what I was doing there you didn't
go to school there uh-huh
what'd you do on campus probably if I
can you know Pervin out but the good
thing is getting longer than the bag
dude yeah I'm not mad at it dude it I
had to get my back waxing the other day
some of my top hair got caught up in
some hollaback character and that's
called the Holy Grail yeah when that
happens the redneck tuxedo oh you can
hear that's that [ __ ] redneck taint
right there
some with them I don't care they don't
give a [ __ ] if you let them go or not
they're [ __ ] toads dude look at them
I saw a pet toad really yeah but mud in
a laundry basket in the use big brother
that is one of definitely most lesbian
things I've ever heard somebody do that
toad laundry basket full of mud yeah
your daughter's gonna be a lesbian you
give her a laundry basket and you put so
much a mud and a frog in it yeah it was
interesting for sure exhibit I realized
he wasn't having a very nice life so I
feels yeah you get tired dude yeah look
you already look tired and uh probably
tired you look at your tongue on the
phone all night to your dad
Dioner tell you tell you how not to say
the n-word on today's show
okay tell me the that sleepwalks but is
happy about it that's your life you
always smile with your [ __ ] eyes how
can you smile and open your eyes at the
same time Betty you can't bro Bechet you
[ __ ] can't do it - bro you're changin
I can make ya'll laugh and steal
everything in this [ __ ]
what do you see me do you guys are out
of your minds man out of your minds
but bro were we just talking about I am
truly Scott hellish it Spanish growing
pink it's a shitty doggy you're from a
foggy land yeah
I haven't had a girl come up to me last
night at the Comedy Store and she works
in the office and she goes I'm no I'm
not because I'm not saying this because
I think you need it I heard you talk
about the bags in your eyes there's a
procedure that we do with ops I work at
where we inject these things into the
bad guys and there you're the man I have
bags under your eyes I kind of have some
bag I carry right now never noticed that
one time I got Trump bag no.8 - ball
sacks a lot but once she said those
again I don't [ __ ] you water Marlins
when I was growing up as a fruit bro so
you taught that yeah see to you that's
fair and that's why you don't speak
Spanish man yeah you're right man
but could you learn Spanish I took
French for four years advanced French in
high school advanced friends I get
British on the croissant hunter yeah
Doug dude I could see you at a bakery at
night just hunting croissants bruh
are making delicious chocolate
croissants yeah what a [ __ ] creep do
you like this
you look like the guy who sell pig in a
blanket
I do look like that guy I definitely
look I love peeking the blankets dude
you look like the biggest dude on the
little league baseball team that's not
good at baseball like dude good thing we
got Ernie and then you [ __ ] go to the
first game and Ernie [ __ ] sucks
bro they put him in the outfield but
past the fence I just watch the car the
guy would have tic tacs in his pocket
but not in the box just like with lint
on them like I guess I'll take on these
mints you look like you jack off there
who's the boss why are these tic tacs
wait a little little sweaters detect
that a first show do I love orange tic
tac though man how good are they it's
not a mint
that's a [ __ ] candy I mean I breath
better I don't know if they make your
breath better they make your mouth
orange and they make you seem like I
think up anybody that's eating them on
the regular deaf City was like you know
crazy yeah they're delicious though
they're delicious but that's a problem
you eat 14 at once and probably whole
box at one time right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]